.
Thank you.
I'll call the meeting to order.
This is an executive session of the Resources, Recreation, and Development Committee.
I will first thing, I would like to ask all to rise so we can salute the flag.
Yes, please join me in a pledge to our flag.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for which it stands, one nation, under God, neither the bull, the liberty and justice for all.
Be seated.
All right.
First on the agenda is Senate Bill 56 relative to payments of a restoration of certain jurisdictional resource losses.
And Chair recognizes Representative Lamontagne for a motion.
I make a motion to pass.
Motion to pass.
Is there a second?
Representative Rung seconds the motion.
Representative Lamontagne, would you like to speak to your motion?
Yes, I have to say when I first looked at the bill, I thought that we shouldn't make it easier not to get the important work done and to allow lieu of payment but after hearing more testimony about it I understand it's it would make it much more effective to get some of these impact projects done and sort of expedite that whole process.
Representative Rung, would you like to speak to your second?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I ditto what Representative LaMontagne said, but also it was clear from the testimony from DOT, DES, and the New Hampshire General Contractors Association that watershed renewal programs or repair programs will actually be of a higher quality with this program than they would otherwise.
Thank you very much.
Anyone else wish to speak on the motion?
Seeing none, on Senate Bill 56, the motion ought to pass.
Will the clerk please call the roll?
Thank you, Chair.
Representative Harb.
Yes.
Representative Gould.
Representative Horgan.
roll thank you chair uh representative harb yes representative goulds yes representative horrigan yes clerk votes yes representative healy yes representative wolf representative mcguez here representative donnelly yes Yes.
Representative Dunn?
Yes.
Representative Vail?
Representative Rung?
Yes.
Representative Kelly?
Representative Simpson?
Yes.
Representative Baldwin?
Representative Darby?
Yes.
Representative Hoyt?
Representative Lamontagne?
Yes.
Representative Lovett?
Yes, but it's Representative Howard.
Okay, that's...
Okay.
And Representative Ryan?
Yes.
And Representative Renzullo?
19 to 0.
Motion passes.
Consent?
Yeah.
Okay, consent, consent.
Okay.
It's consent.
I'm going to skip over 60 at the moment.
We are waiting for an amendment on it.
So the next two you've got to skip.
Okay.
Skip to the third.
All right.
Well, okay.
Then another skip.
We've got to do an amendment for 160 as well.
And let's get through the 164 and 229.
Okay, well, first I'd like to recognize Representative Howard and you're replacing Representative Lovett.
Thank you very much.
All right, well, Senate Bill, let's go to Senate Bill 164, and I apologize.
It's relative to consideration of biodiversity in the land and community heritage investment program.
I recognize Representative Harb for a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I'd make a motion inexpedient to legislate on SB 164.
Do I have a second?
Representative Rung seconds.
Representative Harb, would you like to speak to your motion?
Yes, thank you, Chair.
Just very briefly, I think this bill would cause more problems than it would solve, and I don't think it's necessary.
So that's why I move to ITL.
Representative Runk, would you like to?
Yeah, I just think it needs a little more work.
I know during testimony, it was brought out that it doesn't include some of life species like fungi and algae.
And so, I think it just needs a little more work.
Is there anyone else who would like to speak to the motion of ITL.
Representative Vail.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I actually think this is a great concept, and I like that we are looking to consider biodiversity in LCHIP, but I also feel that we have a board of directors in Elchip, and I did not hear them weighing in as a group.
And so for that reason, I think, and for the reason that it doesn't include all the species and maybe phylums and genres.
So thank you so much for bringing this forward, but at this point, I think it's not ready.
Thank you.
Is there anyone else who wishes to speak on the motion of ITL?
Seeing none.
Motion on Senate Bill 164.
Will this clerk please call the roll thank you chair on senate bill 164 representative harb yes representative goulds yes representative horgan yes clerk votes yes representative healy Yes.
Representative Wolfe?
Yes.
Representative McHugh?
Representative Donnelly?
Yes.
Representative Dunn?
Representative...
Yes.
Representative McHugh?
Representative Donnelly?
Yes.
Representative Dunn?
Representative Vail?
Yes.
Representative Wrong?
Representative Kelly?
Yes.
Representative Simpson?
No.
Representative Baldwin?
Yes.
Representative Darby?
Representative Hoyt?
Yes.
Representative LaMontagne?
No.
Representative Howard?
Representative Ryan?
No.
And Representative Renzulu?
Yes.
Okay.
The vote is 16 to 4.
The vote passes.
All right.
Obviously, that's not going to be on the – let's see.
Is there – is there going to be a – I will be writing the blurb on the motion.
and is there anyone who will be writing the of a minority and is there anyone who will be writing a minority report?
Yes, it sounds like there will be a minority report.
Can we get back to you about which one of us will write that?
Yeah.
And when would you like it?
Sometime today.
Okay, great.
Thanks.
Because I do have to get these in.
Okay.
we're finished on 164.
And we'll go to House Bill, assuming Senate Bill 229, relative to administration of certain wetland permits by the Department of Environmental Services.
And Representative Donnelly, for motion.
I'd like to make a motion, Mr.
Chair, to ought to pass.
Motion I'll ought to pass.
Is there a second?
Second by Representative Healy.
Would you like to speak to your motion, Representative Donnelly?
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Yes, I believe that this would simplify some of the things that are needed in certain wetland permitting.
And also, as DES pointed out, that the domestic sewage with single-family dwellings would be a better way of managing this.
So I think this would be a good thing to clarify and simplify.
Thank you.
Representative Healy, would you like to speak to your second?
We pretty much covered what was said, and just wanted to make sure that it was pointed out that he said it really was just fixing small issues in the permitting process.
All right.
Is there anyone else who wishes to speak on the motion?
Seeing no one, the clerk please call the roll.
Yes.
For Arch Pass on Senate Bill 229, Representative Harp.
Representative Goulds.
Yes.
Representative Horgan.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Harp.
Yes.
Representative Gould.
Representative Horgan.
Yes.
Clerk votes, yes.
Representative Healy.
Yes.
Representative Wolfe.
Representative McHugh.
Yes.
Representative Donnelly.
Representative Dunn.
Yes.
Representative Vail.
Representative Rung.
Yes.
Representative Kelly.
Representative Simpson.
Yes.
Representative Rung.
Representative Kelly.
Yes.
Representative Simpson.
Representative Baldwin.
Yes.
Representative Darby.
Representative Hoyt.
Yes.
Representative LeMontagne.
Representative Howard.
Yes.
Representative Ryan.
Representative Renzullo.
Yes.
That's 20 to 0.
20 to 0.
Consent.
Representative Renzullo.
um there's a fiscal note on it um so does it have to go on the regular calendar mr chair i don't believe so because uh even though there's a fiscal note on it.
So does it have to go on the regular calendar, Mr.
Chair?
I don't believe so because even though it was a fiscal note, it was not an early bill.
Oh, okay.
So, yeah, I don't believe so.
Okay, thank you.
If it gets bounced back, my bad.
Okay, consent.
Okay.
All right.
We are waiting for amendments on two bills.
Okay.
I'll recess for about 10 minutes.
Thank you.
And I'd like to do, we have the amendment now for Senate Bill 160.
Yes, Senate Bill 160.
and first I'll accept the motions of of of of First, I'll accept the motion of ought to pass, Representative Vail.
I move ought to pass on Senate Bill 160.
And you also, do you have an amendment?
Yes, Mr.
Chair.
And further, I would like to introduce amendment 1519H to Senate Bill 160.
I did make an error in that I needed a second on ought to pass.
Representative Rung seconds ought to pass.
We'll go into the amendment now and then other discussion on ought to pass.
We're going to move the amendment first.
This is on amendment, is it 1519?
Yes, Mr.
Chair.
And is there a second on the amendment?
Representative Darby, I haven't heard from him yet.
Shocking, right?
What have you, a large item?
I second the amendment 1519H.
Thank you.
Representative Vail, would you like to speak to your amendment?
Yes, I would, Mr.
Chair.
This is a very simple amendment.
It says to amend the title of the bill by replacing it with relative to the use of OHRVs on designated trails and it also deletes section 3 and renumbers the original section 4 to read as 3 and I'll tell you the reason why we look to get this amended.
I think in the testimony that we heard that the first part of the bill is super important.
It's causing a lot of problems and we want to make sure that fishing game has relief and that the people in the area also do.
And I believe that that part of the bill was consistent with the Commission the OHRV 1188 Commission that has been meeting I think they've had four meetings so far so for the amendment the reason basically is with that 1188 Commission we really I we don't want to step on toes I think as a committee we need to let that Commission do its work and we need them to where they came to us without a position on the bill and they had concerns as well as a lot of information to share that we should let that commission with all of the stakeholders present go through that part of the bill.
So I'm asking for people to vote with me on to pass as amended on this bill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you.
Representative Brown, would you like to speak to your second?
No, I think Senator Vail, Representative Vail did a great job.
I'm giving you a promotion.
Anyone else like to speak to the bill?
I will speak to the amendment.
Okay.
On the amendment, on Amendment 1519, will the clerk please call the roll?
The amendment.
Representative Harb.
Yes.
Representative R Howard?
Representative Hoyt.
Yes.
Representative LaMontagne.
Representative Howard.
Yes.
Representative Ryan.
Representative Renzullo.
Yes.
That's 20 to 0.
On the ought to pass as amended.
Representative Vail, would you like to speak to your motion?
I really don't have anything further to add, Mr.
Chair.
Representative Rung, would you like to speak to...
Yeah, I thought Representative Darby, I forget which second he had.
Sorry, I let him have a shot.
I think Representative Bale expressed my concerns that eliminating the Montana loophole to get ahead of OHRVs on roads where they're not currently permitted is important, yet the clauses from Section 3 haven't been appropriately studied yet, so the OHRB committee should study those before we vote on them.
So I'd urge the committee to vote OTPA.
Thank you.
Is there anyone else who wishes to speak on the motion about to pass as amended?
Seeing none, will the clerk please call the roll on Senate Bill 160?
Okay.
Thank you.
Representative Harb?
Yes.
Representative Gould?
Representative Horgan?
Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy.
Yes.
Representative Wolfe.
Representative McHugh.
Yes.
Representative Donnelly.
Representative Dunn.
Yes.
Representative Bale.
Representative Rung.
Yes.
Representative Kelly.
Representative Simpson.
Yes.
Representative Baldwin.
Thank you.
Yes.
Representative Kelly.
Representative Simpson.
Yes.
Representative Baldwin.
Representative Darby.
Yes.
Representative Hoyt.
Representative Lamontagne.
Yes.
Representative Howard.
Representative Ryan.
Yes.
And Representative Prince-Elo.
20 to zero.
Okay.
Having passed, that's 20 to nothing.
Consent?
Non-consent?
Oppose the hearing on Senate Bill 160.
I guess we have an amendment on 60, Senate Bill 60, which we are also waiting for.
And it may be passed out.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'll let folks look at it for a minute.
The – Okay.
The, you want to, why don't I open up discussion so you can explain, you want to explain all of the, what's in it?
Exactly.
I'm just looking for one.
All right.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh.
You get your thing on.
Okay.
All right.
I'll open the discussion.
This is an amendment that we just had a correction on.
We had a work session with Mr.
Deers, who helped us work through it.
is this is an omnibus amendment.
So there was some things that we needed to be clarified.
And that since I'm going to ask Mr.
Dears if he'd like to.
Well, if you want to speak to just a sec, just one or, you know, just a little bit about what it is on this amendment.
And so we had your input on it, but I think there's some people who might have been missing that and might have been missing what you have here.
Sorry to pull you in, but you're good at this.
No, no, I'm not.
We don't have a motion on the floor.
Well, I don't know.
I don't think I have to do any motion yet.
Just taking information.
Great.
Thank you for the record.
My name is Ted Deers.
I'm the Assistant Director of the Water Division at the New Hampshire Department of Environmental Services.
Thank you.
I appreciate the fluttering about of papers here on this bill this morning.
It is, as we spoke about last time at the work session, it took a little bit to work through the whole, all these provisions.
The provisions themselves end up being very simple.
We talked last time about that most of these really are putting some of what would be kind of rule-type things in statute.
That was something Mr.
McGue was interested in, and we had that conversation, and you'll see that those are the kinds of things that have been added in.
We talked about timeframes, and one of the things about timeframes was making sure that people had adequate opportunity to be able to respond.
And so I think Representative Harb and others had some good ideas about adding some additional time for people to be able to respond.
So those have been added into this amendment after that discussion.
And I think those were the primary pieces that ended up being part of the bill.
we had a good discussion I think about the last provision which was somewhat complicated to understand relative to how we calculate nutrient effluent criteria for wastewater treatment plants.
I think that was a fruitful conversation.
I think everybody kind of came around to understanding how that works and why this is important to provide flexibility.
And I had provided some rule language that would go along with that particular provision at the last time, which showed how we would address that in our rules based on the statute.
I think that those were the primary activities.
I also sent around to you a quick summary that went through each of the provisions that should have gone out in your email.
And that was sort of the beginnings of maybe a blurb at some point if we can get around to that here today.
And I'm happy to help out in any way on writing that.
There are a fair number of provisions here.
So I would just say that while we're in informational session, if the chair is okay with it, I'd be happy to entertain any questions and be happy to explain further where we ended up with the amendment.
Representative Vail.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I have a summary of the bill that I could run by you, and that would be appropriate.
So I have Senate Bill 60 filed at the request of the department.
Well, now you're getting into – maybe I should call this to order.
Yeah.
I think we're getting into some testimony, which I think we can accept, which we should accept as part of the hearing.
Pardon?
She doesn't have any questions.
Yeah.
Well, do you have any question of him?
Okay, actually, she doesn't have any.
Does anyone else have any questions of Mr.
Dears?
Seeing none, I guess I have no questions.
Let me open the hearing then on the executive session.
Thank you very much.
If you have any questions during the session, I'll be here and available.
Thank you.
All right, opening the hearing on the executive session for Senate Bill 60.
And the chair recognizes Representative Vail for a motion.
I move on to pass.
Motion of ought to pass.
Do I have a second?
Representative Darby?
I second the motion ought to pass on Senate Bill 60.
Okay.
We'll go right to the amendment.
You have an amendment.
I move ought to pass on Amendment 1635H.
Amendment 1635H.
So I hear a second.
Representative Darby.
I second the motion to amend Senate Bill 60 with Amendment 1635H.
Representative Vail, would you like to speak to your amendment?
Yes, I would.
And I did write something up that I'm hoping describes the bill as well as possible as amended.
The bill makes changes to existing statutes that clarify responsibilities of DES and ensuring compliance with federal water quality standards.
And the bill also establishes processing times for requests for certifications, defines the time period for acting on federally required certifications, and sets public notice and hearing requirements for certification requests.
Additionally, the bill clarifies the requirement for water conservation for both large surface water and groundwater withdrawals, and it removes language that prohibits the use of flow statistics 7Q10 in the calculation of nutrient effluent limits from wastewater treatment plants.
Furthermore, I have section by section which RSAs get changed, but I will spare you unless you would like to hear more about that.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you.
That was on the bill itself, but the amendment is just clarification of segments of the original bill?
Yes, that is the case, Mr.
Chair.
They're mostly just small tweaks and things that we felt would add confusion versus the clarifications that this bill and amendment seek to make.
Representative Darby on the amendment.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Yes, I agree.
I concur with Representative Vail.
There was a couple of minor clarifications for some inconsistencies that were clarified in the amendment.
And it's as we discussed during the work session.
Anyone else wish to speak on the amendment?
On Amendment 1635 for Senate Bill 60, will the clerk please call the roll?
Yes.
Representative Harb.
Representative Goulds.
Yes.
Representative Horgan.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy.
Yes.
Representative Goulds.
Representative Horgan.
Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy.
Yes.
Representative Wolfe.
Representative McHugh.
Yes.
Representative Donnelly.
Representative Dunn.
Yes.
Representative Vail.
Representative Rung.
Yes.
Representative Kelly.
Representative Simpson.
Yes.
Representative Rung.
Representative Kelly.
Yes.
Representative Simpson.
Representative Baldwin.
Yes.
Representative Darby.
Representative Hoyt.
Yes.
Representative LaMontagne.
Representative Howard.
Yes.
Representative Ryan.
Representative Renzi Lu.
Yes.
It's 20 to 0.
20 to 0 on the motion of ought to pass as amended.
Representative Vail, do you have any additional comments?
I have no further comments, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you.
Representative Darby, on your second, do you have any additional comments?
I'll just state briefly that the amended bill makes a number of important refinements to existing water quality statutes to increase flexibility without risking safety.
In particular, things that are important are adding public hearings for water withdrawal certification requests and correcting the statute references for rules regarding large water withdrawals under the Clean Water Act.
And so I urge the committee to vote ought to pass as amended on House Bill 60 as amended.
Thank you.
Anyone else wish to speak on the motion of ought to pass as amended?
Seeing no one, will the clerk please call the roll?
Yes.
On Senate Bill 60 as amended, Representative Harb.
Representative Gould.
Yes.
Representative Horgan.
On Senate Bill 60 as amended, Representative Harv.
Yes.
Representative Gould.
Representative Horgan.
Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy.
Yes.
Representative Wolfe.
Representative McHugh.
Yes.
Representative Donnelly.
Representative Dunn.
Yes.
Representative Vail.
Representative Rung.
Yes.
Representative Vail?
Representative Rung?
Yes.
Representative Kelly?
Representative Simpson?
Yes.
Representative Baldwin?
Representative Darby?
Yes.
Representative Coit?
Representative Lamontagne?
Yes.
Representative Howard?
Representative Ryan?
Yes.
Representative Lamontagne.
Representative Howard.
Yes.
Representative Bryan.
And Representative Renzullo.
Yes.
That's 20 to 0.
Motion passes.
Okay.
Well, yes for consent.
Is there any more business we need to take up at this time?
I think we've gotten the five bills that were on the agenda.
We do have a work session this afternoon at 2 o'clock.
I guess it's a long lunch unless we want to discuss something.
Representative Rugg.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I also see we have a work session scheduled on May 10th.
Yep.
And that's also on Senate Bill 11, correct?
So I was just wondering why we were having two work sessions.
Because we may need a third.
We may need a third one.
This is the second year for this bill.
and so I can always erase This is the second year for this bill.
And so I can always erase that.
But I don't see us coming to a conclusion at the end of our work session today.
if we do come to a conclusion, we still have to work out, well, we still have to come to a point where we will have to exact the bill.
We could change that.
Again, I can always cross things out and write something else in no i i just um so you know i the history of the bill is it was voted interim study and voted recommended to bring back so there's already been some work on this bill from last year that's why i was wondering why we needed multiple work sessions on it but if you read read the interim study, there was division in how the bill should finally come out.
There was agreement on a probable need, but there was not agreement on how it would finally look.
There was general agreement, but we need to work some things out.
A lot of things.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Do I understand that if we do come to some kind of resolution today, you'd be able to perhaps change that work session into an exec session?
No, I cannot do that.
That needs, would need, the full requirement of a hearing.
Not a hearing, of a published notice for an executive.
right my question was was, what's the deadline for that public hearing for next Wednesday?
Today.
Okay.
We might have a consecutive session next Wednesday.
Well, no, I didn't say that.
That was my question.
Next Wednesday, we don't have an executive session for next Wednesday.
We have a work session for next Wednesday.
Could that, if we finish up today, could that work session be changed to an executive session?
It's before Thursday.
Well, I think if I had to do that, I would have to do it on the floor tomorrow to change it.
Pardon?
Can you go in the next half an hour and add, don't delete, but add the exec session on the same bill the same day we have the work session so we could follow the work and then go to exec?
We could.
Somebody told me you might have a half an hour to do that.
I don't know timing yeah that's that way we have it both if we need the work session we have it if we need to continue the exec we can continue it but if we work it all out we could finish it that day i don't know gee my arm gets twisted.
Oh, good.
Mr.
Chairman, you have until 3 o'clock today.
You have until 3 o'clock today to put it in the calendar.
But I would have to get it to the person in front of 12.
That's the agreement with the – actually, it's 11, 15, 12 and 1.
that's the agreement with you can get that that is the agreement that you have.
Oh, 1 o'clock for committee services?
Yep.
Or with the agreement of the ranking member, we could do exec session anytime, right?
Not out of a – I think not out of a work session.
I think out of a hearing.
Not out of a not I think we're not out of a work session.
Not out of a work session.
I could check with the clerk on that, but I would think.
I wouldn't agree to it anyway.
I want to go right to the end from the fourth I'll have it put on unfortunately what's going to happen if you have it put on.
Unfortunately, what's going to happen, if you have it put on, people are going to come and expect to have it taken care of.
So at any rate, if you put it on, you can take it off.
Oh.
It can be canceled.
I can cancel it.
Yeah, so if you put it on and then we see what happens this afternoon, it looks like, no, it ain't going anywhere.
We need a lot more work.
You can take it off.
If you don't put it on, we're another day.
People do keep track.
Just a suggestion.
Yeah, that's true.
Hey, who's running this place?
Who's running this place?
You're running it with some good suggestions.
I don't blame you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Yeah, I agree with my colleague from Newbury.
I think add the executive session, because if it takes us two work sessions and we don't have consensus, I don't think adding a third work session is going to do it.
We're just going to have to bring it to a vote.
That's on, Mr.
Chairman, on Senate Bill 11?
Oh, I haven't.
Really?
Okay.
I thought we were going to maybe be unanimous on that one.
I guess we'll wait to get today's work session.
Okay.
I'll put in another.
I'll to be, if this was the last session, I could call it right away.
It used to be that way in the last session.
I just want to punish it for taking away my powers.
This is the last session.
Let's let them go.
Just kidding.
I'll put it.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I do have another matter to bring up.
You only got one.
That one wasn't mine.
Just that you had mentioned something about moving on to the retained bills and at what point we would be able to do that.
And the committee of conference season is over for us.
Can you use the microphone?
Oh, not everybody can hear.
It was discussed at the chair's meeting that once we, into June, we can work on retained bills, especially if we don't have a lot of committee conference issues.
Some committees have a lot of bills going back and forth.
I think we will have one.
I think we just got one ourselves here today.
But I don't think we have that many.
So we can work on the builds that we have retained on the month of June.
The only issue is you can get the work done, but you can't dispose of the stuff.
It has to go to November when you have your final vote, and then it goes to the final vote is, I guess, the first in November.
So you have to.
But you can have the hearings.
you can have the hearings.
You can do all, you can, you can have the, uh, the sessions and you can, you can come to an agreement and you can, you can even take your vote.
It's just that you can't have, uh, you can't, it doesn't, it doesn't get disposed of.
Don't go back to the House.
So we can vote.
Yeah.
But so we can clean if we're good about it.
And I know we have a couple of bills that we retain simply by request.
to I think there was a couple of bills like that that we're going to we said we were going to not pass but we were retained by request by the people who by the sponsors and we agreed agree.
So we can do that.
So, yeah, I had planned on doing that during June.
Would we schedule work sessions for those bills?
We could do it as work session.
I think we can do it as work session, but we'd probably have to have a public session.
Well, they're public anyway.
Right.
But if we have to do any disposition.
Then he's got to be scheduled again for a vote.
He's got to be scheduled as a work session.
But we can't vote until November.
No, we vote in the committee and then get it off our plate.
It doesn't go to the House for the House to vote on.
Thank you.
But we can't vote until November.
No, we vote in the committee and then get it off our plate.
It doesn't go to the House for the House to vote on.
Every bill has to go to the House.
We vote on it here, but it doesn't go to the House until November.
We'll work on it.
We'll figure it out.
I just have one more process question, and that's about the committees of conference or the bills coming back.
So for the newer people, our bills went over to the Senate.
They did what they did.
And did they come back to you for you to look at the changes they might have made to whether or not we would concede to their changes?
Yes.
If you could walk us through that.
I'd be a fool to do it by myself.
I didn't know what you meant.
But you could.
I could if I wanted, but you don't do that.
I mean, it's within the authority, but it's not very smart.
So what usually is done is if, like, if you're having a session, bring it up.
Or a lot of times I'll get that information sometimes on the day of a hearing, excuse me, of a session day, and I'll'll just find people and get their thoughts yeah excuse me I only have three things to do it's either concur non-concur or non-concur and ask for a committee conference.
So, it's a concur, but usually it's a concur.
So I would ask people, just basically, and get a consensus.
All right.
I would get a consensus from the, yeah.
Usually, because it's pretty normal.
And then on a committee of conference, I have to recommend people to the speaker, and he will, usually follows who I would recommend.
Requirement is that you have had to have voted for the House position on the bill.
Thank you so much for going over that.
I do remember just coming, we are coming in and we're having a hearing or we're having a work session or for some reason meeting and hearing about the bills coming back one by one as they do.
So we'll just take this as it goes and learn from it.
Should be pretty to see what's going to happen yeah you'll get sent messages thank you so much for covering those things I just have one more thing if you'll indulge me Mr..
Chair.
Go ahead.
Four follow-ups is definitely my limit.
Just to, we really need to be careful to use our microphones.
When I went back to look at all the hearings on SB11, I saw that we could not hear my voice.
Now, I know enough about this equipment to understand how it works, and I know that I need to have it right in front of me for people to hear me.
I think I'm speaking into it but I know that there are members in here have hearing impairments and they are not hearing everything and that is deeply disturbing to me.
So I hope that we'll all take time to practice with our microphones and make sure that every word that we say is being said into it um i know that with hearing aids and devices that when you turn them up as far as they will go you hear every rustle of paper and it can be excruciating and exhausting so let's just try to be the best at this i think all committees struggle with the equipment.
That is true, but I think their equipment now is head and shoulders better than what we had during last session.
It was disaster, especially when you had half the place was coming in on screen.
And it was all Zoom.
And we didn't have this many microphones.
So I think, I mean, usually it's pretty good, the ones I've heard for now, but not like me.
I have a tendency to leave this off.
And I lean back.
All right.
Anything else?
Questions?
Two o'clock.
Five minutes of two.
Five?
Yeah.
The year after two o'clock.
Five minutes of two.
Five minutes?
Yeah, the air after two o'clock.
Thank you.
make a statement or however you want to do it.
We're in a work session.
It's all, you know, kind of just whatever works.
Yeah, you should.
Thank you, Chairman Renzullo and committee members.
We don't really have an opening statement.
Again, I'm Ben Wilson.
I'm the director of the Division of Historical Resources.
And within our division, we house the state archaeologists.
The state archaeologists.
So I'd like to introduce Mark Doporowski, who is our state archaeologist.
And he's actually the professional when it comes to these issues of unmarked graves and remains and the processes involved and that sort of thing.
So I think we could, if the committee just wanted to ask questions, we'll do our best to answer them and go from there.
If I'm not mistaken, Representative Vail, you, the last time I think you asked some very, you started us off with a very interesting question.
Would you like to say it for you?
or would you like to?
Please, Mr.
Chair, if you would indulge me to go ahead and do that for me we talked about a lot of different things thank you I think it was basically if you're walking out in your backyard and you step on a skull, what happens?
Where do you go from there?
There's a whole lot of information.
There's a whole lot of procedure that goes on, some of which I think eventually ends up relative to this bill.
So you could just give us an idea of what happens when you find the skull.
So first you try not to scream.
Yeah.
And don't break it.
But I'm going to turn that question over to the state archaeologists.
Okay.
So upon finding human remains, you call the local police.
Usually state law enforcement will respond, but ultimately the medical examiner's office is in charge until the remains are either determined to be part of a homicide or a crime.
They stay with the medical examiner's office.
If they're found to be of historical nature and there's no fall to play, they come, they're notified, our office is notified.
So that's the process.
If you find human remains of any sort, you definitely call your local law enforcement.
They'll take it from there.
Okay, now, if you find that it is of a historical nature, Here we go.
Okay, now, if you find that it is of a historical nature, what happens then?
So that's when our office comes into the picture, and what's going to happen there is the process of, first and foremost, we're going to recommend that the human remains are preserved in place, which means whatever you dug up already, you put back and you preserve it.
Some cases, you can't do that, right?
So there's a road project that has to go through or something else like that.
In that case, the remains need to be, after consultation with the community that the remains belong to, if it's possible to identify them, they go through a process of a consultation.
It's a lawn-drawn process.
Eventually, the remains will be excavated out.
They'll be appropriately treated and ultimately repatriated in consultation again with the local community or the community, the dissentant community.
there's some things in here though that just to bring up it's not a matter of that when you find human remains as part of a construction project it gets shut down period that's that so some of the language in here is a little inconsistent with the actual procedures it's not a quick moving thing if I'm explaining that correctly to you I hope I'm explaining that in a way you can understand it's not something that just you call the, they notify me and we got to corrode there and excavate the remains.
That's not how it happens.
Well, I don't want to take away I don't want to have me ask all the questions.
Do any other people who Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
I think that Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
I think that Chairman Renzullo was pushing it to the limit when he talked about a skull.
But what happens if you come across something else that may be historic?
And how do you know that it's historic you're not speaking of human remains then no not necessarily just a artifact completely depends on the context so if it's a private property owner is digging in his backyard and he finds a stone tool that's 3 000 years old nothing there's no unless there's a permit involved there's's really no regulation.
Okay.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
Just kind of reframe the discussion again, because I think at one point you were referring to current law.
And at one point you were referring to the piece of legislation in front of us.
So can you just be clear in your response when you're referring to what currently happens, current process, current statute?
So I think the chairman was asking, can you walk us through what happens now under current statute, current process, when there's any kind of project somebody's putting in a pool or there's a road project and human remains of any kind is uncovered.
Sure.
When human remains are uncovered, it doesn't matter what the...
Okay.
So I believe I understood you to say that you, of course, notify local authorities.
It's under the jurisdiction of the ME.
They make the determination if it's part of a crime, and they then determine whether it's historical and then hand off to you and the process you outlined, you already outlined.
And that's current law or remains of any origin.
I would just add a caveat to that.
The ME's office does the best they can to make the determination.
Sometimes they have to consult with us or another specialist, sometimes at UNH or another university, to really make that determination.
And there has been cases where they turn that case over as being historic, and then we throw it back to them saying, after some additional analysis, but no, it's not.
So there is sometimes a little bit back and forth.
But overall the the process you described is accurate law enforcement emmy's office when the termination is made as historic then it comes to us further question all right so to be clear that's all in current statute regardless of the type of historical remains or the origin species or otherwise right if it has to do with human remains and so separately then can you comment on the legislation in front of us what what that does because i you you i saw you looking at it you were starting to refer to that right we'd like to separately talk about that right so even even if so as an archaeologist if i'm doing an excavation and i run into human remains it gets shut down there's no there's no um um there's no allowances for oh well you're an archaeologist doing this you can continue to excavate these human remains as long as you notify the state archaeologists that that's not how it currently works if human remains are discovered no matter what you're doing whether you're digging a pool in your backyard or it's a big highway project or it's an academic study human remains shut a project down until there's an additional investigation that occurs current law okay thank you uh mr chair thank you for taking question.
So let's talk about the part then once you've decided they are historic remains and need disposition.
I think you're referring to the process that's in 227C8A through G in general.
And it seems like there's a case called out for Native Americans, and then there's another general case for other individuals.
And I was wondering if you could talk about the other individual's case and what you do in that case.
The only real difference between other individuals and Native Americans is that with Native Americans, there's federal law as well that we have to adhere to, NAGPRA, the Native American Grave Protection and Repatriation Act.
But I guess the additional thing is we consult with the descendant community regardless of what the ethnicity is.
With Native Americans, it's usually not an actual family.
For example, if we are dealing with a European-American individual, we'll try and track down that actual family name and the descendants.
We don't have that luxury with a lot of Native American remains, so it's more of a descendant community, and it would be the same for a lot of the African-American remains solely because a lot of these individuals are buried in non-marked graves.
For a follow-up.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thanks for the explanation.
So can you talk about the process that you use now for, again, not Native American remains because, like you said, there is explicit statute compliant with federal law, but the the process you use to track down the, you know, the descendant community or descendants for other people.
Yeah, and again, it's the same process for European Americans and Native Americans.
It's trying to identify the descendant community, and like I said, with Caucasians, we're usually able, usually able to get a little bit closer to actually like a family name and be able to talk to the next of kin as opposed to just the generic descendant community.
But the process is the same as I outlined once it comes to our office.
The first thing we're always going to recommend is preservation in place, which is to say, do not excavate the human remains.
Whatever has already been disturbed, put back as carefully carefully as possible and rebury that is always the ultimate goal as far as our department division is concerned like i said there are cases where where that is not possible and again after consultation and identification of the descendant community or the local community or the kin the next of kin they would help make the decision on exactly what's going to happen.
But like I said, in a lot of cases, if it's a mandated project that's going to happen, they are excavated eventually.
And again, then it's additional consultation to decide how they're going to be repatriated.
John?
Thank you, Mr.
Trane.
Thank you for taking my question.
You mentioned a few minutes ago that there was some discrepancies in the bill that you'd like to see fixed.
Could you explain what those are?
I'm not saying they need to be fixed.
I'm just saying that it does not adhere to the law.
And personally, I don't think morally it's even if you're an archaeologist doing excavation, you can't just continue digging human remains.
That's a little different than the other material that we're excavating.
Human remains are a special case in my opinion.
Can you just be a little more specific about what section of the bill you think needs that work the majority of the bill actually talks about academic excavation I would say a lot of it talks about a professional archaeologist excavating a professional archaeologist it's almost on every page So So for example, part 1b, if a professional archaeologist is directing a long-term systematic archaeological research, that is research designed to continue, yada yada, right there on, and it continuously talks about professional archaeologists, professional archaeologists, and specifically what I was saying, part b there, subpart 1, you know, they merely notify the archaeologists and uh specifically what i was saying uh part b there um sub part one you know they merely notify the archaeologists in five five working days to me that that doesn't really mesh with a lot of other notifications and there should be definitely i would i would prefer to see language that says you know all work stops immediately when human remains are discovered all work should stop immediately that's pretty much standard, not just in this state, but across the country.
So, you know, and I may be reading this incorrectly, but it kind of sounds to me like they're allowed to continue excavating the human remains.
You know, yes, they have to notify the state archaeologists in five working days, but I don't see any language that prohibits them from not continuing to excavate the human remains.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And thank you, but it seems to me that you're discussing the amendment, not the bill.
So that's what I have in front of me right now, yes.
Okay.
Mr.
Chairman.
So, thank you, Mr.
Are you looking at the amendment?
Amendment to SB 11?
1597H.
Okay.
So just for clarification, we actually haven't gotten to that yet, but just for your information, that's language out of the Native American Grave Act.
That's right out of existing statute.
Just FYI.
That's not original language.
That's in current statute.
That's where that comes from.
just in case anybody else was wondering too FYI but we haven't got to it yet yeah that's what else was wondering too.
FYI.
But we haven't got to it yet.
Yeah, it comes out of we haven't got to it yet, but it does it comes out of 227 C8.
But again, we haven't gotten to it yet.
I'm happy to walk through it, but I don't think we're going to get to that just yet.
Yeah.
That was not our intent, I don't think.
But just so you know, that's where it comes from.
It's not original language.
Thank you.
Okay.
Any additional questions?
I'll just let you get back to my questions.
let's see the said that there's a consultation with with the Senate You said that there's a consultation with the descendant community, et cetera.
What?
There's a consultation with the descendant community.
What power does the descendant community actually have when you're discussing the issue?
You have somebody who you have the remains and you've identified the remains or at least see what community the remains come from.
What power does the descendants or the descendant community have?
What demands can they put on the state?
Thank you.
Just so people are aware, if you're not speaking into the microphone, then people on YouTube cannot hear a word.
We're hoping to have the whole hearing on record so that we can refer back to it and play it for people.
Yeah.
To get back to my question, what legal rights do they have and what demands can they make of the state in the disposition of the – So it's not necessarily going to be between the state.
It's going to be the federal government with NAGPRA.
If you're dealing with Native American remains, it's federal law.
Okay.
And they can make any demand that they want.
It's consultation though, right?
So it's a back and forth.
An agreement has to be coming.
So they can make whatever demand they want and the other side can try and work out whatever arrangement.
They're highly variable.
Okay.
Relative to the state, what kind of demands?
I'm confused by your question.
In other words, you have to – can the descendants or the descendant community, can they say, well, I want the remains reburied, and I want them reburied with a bronze casket, and I want a parade.
What do they have?
What are their legal rights?
Again, are you asking about Native American remains?
No.
Just in general?
Yes, just in general.
So if it's a non-Native American, then, you know, again, it depends on the situation.
So, you know, the cemeteries that are private cemeteries, the complete control and power of those does belong to the descended community or the next of kin, essentially.
On a town-owned cemetery, that's going to be, the town has ultimate jurisdiction over that.
So if you have remains that are coming from a town-owned cemetery, which a majority of them are in towns, that's the town has, so to speak, has the rights to do what they will.
I mean, you're not going to have a lot of human remains being unexpectedly discovered in a town-owned cemetery i believe you're just trying to ask more about the the cemeteries that aren't really marked on farm says and those are because those are still privately owned even if a new landowner is taken over the rights to that cemetery or that burial ground still lying with the next of kin so even to excavate that you have to actually find the next of kin and get their permission.
So I would imagine the same process would be for their human remains as well.
But just as a follow-up to that, if you did not know that those remains were there...
It's still a private burial ground.
And even if they were...
So if there's no record of there having been a burial ground there but found a grave, that still makes the landowner – that is no longer the landowner's property?
That's beyond my wheel well.
I deal with human remains and how to track down the next of kin.
But, yeah, as far as I know, if you have a private cemetery, and a lot of them are not marked, so a lot of people don't know they're on their their property and in fact it was common procedure for a lot of farmers and whatnot when they sold their property when a new new person would come in they didn't remove the burials they would just remove the headstones and call the graves removed as far as i know i think a burial ground is a burial ground whether or not the markers are still there or not ignorance i don't know if that gets gets you out of it or not.
You had a question?
No.
Oh.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for taking my question.
I was just intrigued by what you said about you try to track down the names of the people.
Does the DNA testing actually bring you to names of people so you can chase their descendants?
How do you figure that out?
So DNA has to be authorized, right?
So a lot of times with Native American communities, they don't want DNA testing done.
But when we're talking about names, we're talking about where we have a burial on a plot of land.
You go back, you look at who owned the land through time, and then you can try and deduce who the family was during the time of burial.
That's how we begin our research.
Follow-up?
Follow-up, follow-up.
So you can tell by the remains when approximately the body was buried?
Not necessarily the remains themselves, but the grave goods, the coffin hardware, things like that can at least narrow it down usually to the century um and a lot of times there are family records if you go to the town um town historical societies things like that um even if you look at the um the plat maps most of them had houses where they were located they had the family name written down on them too so that's kind of how we get started and it's not an easy process and we don't always get the exact next of kin thank you mr chairman and thank you um so under present uh statute if there are human remains found and the medical examiner comes in but the the um decision's been made that this this is an African-American burial ground.
What's the process currently?
I've never had a deal with that yet.
There's been one case that I know of in the state, and that was before my time.
So I would assume that it would be treated the same as all other human remains cases, that we would try and find the next of kin.
If not, we would at least try and identify the descendant community.
And I'm assuming you're asking how we can tell ethnicity.
Go right ahead.
So the ethnicity, a lot of times if there's enough remains, especially cranial features, a forensic anthropologist can, with pretty good accuracy, identify the at least region of the world that the person originally came from.
Not that person, but the lineage came from.
So they have a pretty good record of identifying whether it's Native American remains, African American remains, Caucasian remains.
So again, that would help us identify the descendant community.
If we did have, that's really kind of the only way we would know unless we had some specific artifact burial good that was with the remains that they were african-american would be through that forensic anthropology analysis okay follow up mr chair so if it was determined that it's an african-american remains um then under current statute um your office would uh if there was no next of kin that could be found, let's say they're former slaves, then a descendant community would be identified that could then be of counsel on the disposition of those remains that's currently in statute?
Right.
So what happened, again, I wasn't part of this, but what happened with the African-American burial ground over in Portsmouth, that, again, was the descended community, which was the African-American community from that area, and or people that had ties, African-Americans that had ties to that area in the past, they became the descended community, and they were the ones that were consulted with.
And they're actually still to this day consulted with.
There's still ongoing studies and things with those remains.
So that community is still consulted every time someone proposes a new study or there's a question.
I think that's one thing I was involved in was even to have the remains removed from one facility to another.
I think they ended up going to the Smithsonian.
The community, the Descended community was consulted even on that.
So they're consulted every step of the way for everything that happens to the remains.
Okay.
Just a clarification.
But that is currently in statute.
That's currently what we do.
But it's just practice, not statute.
It may be in statute.
Like I said, I'm not familiar enough with that statute to say that that's exactly what's supposed to happen with African-American remains if it's actually spelled out.
But that's the procedure that we take with all remains is to identify the next of kin or the descendant community.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you for the question.
So just because I think statute is what, we're concerned about here.
Just reading to you from 227 C8E, which is this consultation with other individuals, it only talks about if the professional archaeologist determines human skeletal remains or other than Native American, the requirement to publish a notice of excavation for four consecutive weeks.
So I applaud you, but it appears that you're going above and beyond the current statute with the idea being that the townspeople, there's some heritage maybe within local towns that would see that notification.
But I think one of the concerns that I've heard expressed with respect to the African-American community, the former enslaved people, is that they don't have representatives.
They might not have representatives any longer in those towns because they didn't have descendants there.
And so it sounds like you might not have experienced this case yourself, but I was wondering if you can – first, if you disagree with my reading of the statute, I'd be happy to understand why I'm misinterpreting it.
But I'm also interested if you think that it might be appropriate to add to statute a specific clause about contacting the descendant community in these African American burial cases because of the potential disconnect from when they were essentially property and might not have had family traceability throughout the towns.
I mean, I guess from my perspective, we treat all human remains the same as far as we try to identify the next of kin.
I mean, I kind of understand where you're going with that.
If you want to add that, I guess I really have no opinion either way on that.
Thank you.
Thanks for coming out.
So further in the bill, there's a section down by, I'll say on page two, that it talks about the, basically, a New Hampshire educational or research institutions, museum, historical societies, and other collections shall make reasonable efforts to inventory any remains of other materials from African-American graves.
My question to you is, is that done – how is that done across any other cultures?
We do that for all remains and grave goods, particularly and more so for Native American remains just because of the federal law.'s been around since 1990 but yeah for all remains the ultimate goal is to return them and all the grave goods to a an appropriate burial location again if we can get the input of the next of kin or descended community that's great and that's what we try and do there are definitely cases with, I'll just give you an example.
We had a Caucasian burial.
The closest next of kin lived down in Florida, so again, we don't just advertise in the local paper.
We go and we track these people down as much as we can.
They didn't even remember or know that ancestor, and they wanted nothing to do with it, so in those situations, we go back to the town we can usually make an arrangement with the town to have a plot donated for free by the town and we rebury the remains there we would follow the same procedure for any individual remains that where we did not have a descendant community next of kin or anyone else that was represented and we still treat them with respect and we still try to repatriate them rebury them with dignity and ceremoniously follow up for a follow-up um it talks about uh in materials have you ever had to deal with taking um i don't know other things that may have been buried with an individual what happens with the materials do they ever get separated from the remains and then go into a museum and the remains go?
Has that ever happened?
I'm sure.
Not anymore.
People, it's definitely frowned upon to put anything in a museum anymore that has to do with grave goods.
And with Native American grave goods, it's been highly against the law since 1990.
And you're obligated to inventory.
But, yeah, to answer your question more directly, anything that comes out, and, you know, with Native Americans, you can get some grave goods.
For the most part, when you're talking about Caucasians, burials, you're not really getting grave goods other than what they might have been wearing, like a button or something like that, or the coffin hardware, the wood from the coffin is usually gone.
But all those materials, whatever was recovered, is always buried back with the remains.
I mean, that's our current policy.
I can't speak to what happened five years ago, ten years ago, or the history of it overall.
I know definitely in the past there are definitely things in museums that are grave goods, and you'll hear cases constantly where people are repatriating those as well and reburying those.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for coming, and thank you for taking my question.
Can you make any comment at all about the sort of testimony that we heard?
There's a shed with African Americanrican-american bones in it and i think it was unh uh what the uh bill sponsor was discussing that those remains should be repatriated and and this is part of the reason for the bills there needs to be a process for that can you comment thanks i can honestly say i have no idea about a shed on you said you ain't you and h yeah i've never heard that before in my life so it's news to me okay i wasn't making that up was i so so recently um it was in the media that dartmouth college was using bones in their – was it the sociology?
No, sorry.
Anthropology.
Anthropology program.
They were using them for study materials up until last November.
And so – But those were Native American remains.
Those were Native American remains.
And so these sorts of things still happen.
So I think one of the things, sort of the elephant in the room is that African Americans and Africans did not have the same, were not given the same burial rights in a sense that other groups were.
For instance, Irish and Scottish and runs the gamut.
They were property for the most part.
And so they show up in probate records.
They don't necessarily, they show up as, you know, a young man, you know, was part of, you know, this family's property, so on and so forth.
And they didn't have the same burials that other populations did within the country.
And so much like Native Americans, their burial practices were much different.
You do find various things in African-American African burials.
They had different rituals depended on where they were from, from the continent.
And so the idea I think here is that we're trying to recognize those burials much the way we do with the native indigenous population, plain and simple.
And there aren't the same, as Mark alluded to, the same relatives or probate information.
We can't go back and look at, you know, deed records for properties and see that, you know, the age is necessarily of the graves.
So it's basically trying to treat these these findings these materials these remains much the way we do afford them the same process that the native indigenous population has so so so we don't we it's very very difficult to find relatives next of kin for these remains.
So we go to the next group, which would be, I think, in the original bill, we were being asked to go to the Heritage Trail folks down in Portsmouth.
and then I think DHR was then going to be substituted as the group that should be conferred with.
But we would obviously be also looking to that native population if we could find it.
So I just want to sort of clear up.
I think we're sort of beating around the bush here on what is trying to be done through this legislation.
And we don't have a horse in this race by any stretch of the imagination.
As Mark said, we treat all remains the same way.
The indigenous population is really the only group by federal law that is treated in a different manner, and we stick to that.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you.
And I also have copies of the original bill.
If anybody needs a copy of the original bill.
And you all may need another copy as well.
So I think my question is, I'm trying to tease apart sort of what would happen in the eventuality of your retirement.
It sounds like a lot of this is sort of best practices or morally what you all feel is the best thing to do.
And it seems to me like this bill is trying to get into statute some of the things that maybe aren't in law but are best practice around African American burials.
Is that, am I?
I think you're correct.
Okay, great.
So, when you're looking at the original bill and you're thinking about best practices that you do now around this and what is morally necessary, are there any things you see in the bill that you feel you would change based on your own professional practice?
No.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
This is not totally a question, but I just wanted to point out, again, statute 227 C8 I, which says that, like you pointed out, human remains discovered, acquired after January 1st, 1987 cannot be be retained.
But before 1987, legally, currently, except for they can be retained.
And so I think that's why the sections that you're pointing out are called there, because I think there's concerns that some of these were found before 1987, and then the museums may be able to retain these legally at this point.
So because it's a work section, I didn't think I actually had to form that in the phrase of a question.
I want to just state what the statute says.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thanks for taking the time to go through the bill as amended by the Senate that we got.
But can you also take a look at the redraft, which is essentially the bill as amended by the Senate?
It's virtually identical.
it just puts it in the proper chapter since it was mischaptered, and it's almost identical.
And much of the amendment that you saw is identical to current law.
In fact, the bolded parts are what's new.
So the Native American statutes is current law, and only the bolded pieces on the printed copy that you see of the amendment are new, and that's what's taken the part that refers to suspected African-American burial ground.
That's out of the version as amended by the Senate.
And then on the last page, and all the other bolded parts come right out of the, as amended by the Senate.
All the part that, like on page 2, line 16, state archaeologists shall immediately notify the descendants of the Senate community.
And all that language, that's out of the, as amended by the Senate, but it's just put into the proper chapter.
So OLS advised that it was mischaptered and it should be here.
And that's the purpose of the amendment, just to get it into the right chapter.
So it really doesn't change any of it.
That's why there's no new amended analysis, no new title.
It's identical.
In fact, on page four, section five of the amendment, all of that from line 18 down is verbatim out of the as amended by the Senate version.
It's just more appropriate in 289.11 than it was there.
And that's from OLS.
They said it has to go there because it's relative to cemeteries, not bodies.
So if you can take a minute, since we've been talking a lot about the as amended by the Senate version, if we want to do this, we should do it right and get it in the right chapters of law.
And so if you can take a minute and talk about the amendment and tell us, does this put any undue burden on you?
Since I realize a lot of it's already done and it's great that you treat all remains the same, we would expect nothing less.
but what I really would like to hear is do you, pardon the speech but do you does this put any, the amendment put any undue burden on the division or any undue financial burden?
Can you comment on the amendment?
Well, that's two separate questions.
Or comparing – Financial burden, we could talk about that over at the bar for an hour and a half after that.
But I will...
It's about six questions.
I mean, just give us your opinion.
Your first question doesn't add anything.
We do all this already.
So no additional burden.
This is...
We do this plus more already.
And like I was commenting before, you will never see human remains discovered in New Hampshire where they just call us and we say, yeah yeah just keep digging that just doesn't happen it might say that's okay in here but we just we don't do that you we shut things down you can't just continue to dig on human remains without having a better plan going forward so no there's nothing in here that's that's gonna burden us as far as what we're doing already we already do everything that's in here plus a little more so this is the appropriate place.
Thank you.
I think I had one quick follow-up, and that's on the parts where it talks a lot about professional archaeologists.
I know that seemed like a bit of a surprise, but it wasn't my language.
Only the parts on the first page of the amendment that appear in bold print, and that's in lines 14, 15, 18, 19, and 30 and 31.
Only the bold print stuff, and those words come right out of the Senate bill as amended by the Senate.
All that other stuff is in current statute in 227C8A.
That's existing.
All that stuff about professional archaeologists.
If you think we ought to change that, speak now.
We could change that stuff, but that's in current law.
You could change it if you want.
I'm just saying in practice, it would be a PR nightmare if people were allowed to continue excavating human remains on a construction site, in their backyard, on a pool, or anything else.
So I'm just telling you in practice, people don't just keep taking up human remains without a proper procedure.
We'll leave it to you, but it's current law.
I mean, that's how it is written now.
I didn't put that in the amendment.
That's right there.
Okay.
Excuse me.
Which line are you talking about?
I just got a little lost.
In the amendment, Part B, pretty much Part B, subparts 1 through 4.
And there's some other parts, too, that talk about continuing to excavate, just making a notification.
It's current statute.
And when OLS drafted this amendment, they just advised that when the Senate drafted it, they presented some texts and just said, for lack of a better word, can you write this up?
And then in some discussions, they advised that really it's better placed where the other special treatment for human remains in current statute is, and the only other place that New Hampshire has special treatment for any human remains is in Native American.
We have, you know, some language for special treatment of certain human remains, and that's in Native American.
And so that's the place for this bill in our current RSAs.
So they just basically took Senator Waters and all the other sponsors, who's the prime sponsor, and put it in that chapter.
And it ended up in two places, 227C, and then the other stuff that doesn't refer to bodies, cemetery stuff, gates and monuments and whatnot, in 289, which was the Section 5, and that's verbatim.
If you compare them, it's literally verbatim.
Representative Darby.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So I agree with you that the Humans Remains section should be in 227.
I'm not sure I completely agree with this text yet.
I'd have to review it.
It seems a little extensive.
I also agree that 289.14a, so the original bill tried to do four things.
It tried to talk about human remains, unmarked human remains.
It tried to talk about private burial grounds that are being maintained under section, which is under cemeteries, which is why part of this has to be under cemeteries, which is 289.
But private burial grounds are 289.14a.
And then it also talked about when you are reinterring bodies as well.
It's trying to talk about that.
That's when, you know, if you were to move, which is legal, move a graveyard from one place to another.
Those are three separate situations where you may encounter African-American remains from this period that have specific customs with respect to burials.
The fourth thing that the original bill tried to do was exactly like Representative Johnnelly pointed out, is to return, in particular, human remains that might be in archaeology caches, for lack of a better word, and make sure that those are reinterred.
And I don't see that section in this at all.
Mr.
Chairman, do you mind if I just respond to that?
Because it is, we literally preserved each and every piece of that.
It's the bottom of page one, line 30 continues over to the top of page two, lines one and two.
So all of that stuff was preserved faithfully to preserve the spirit of that bill.
So it reads, the ultimate disposition of the remains and other archeological materials, such as markers, gates, mortar materials, in an African-American burial ground shall be in consultation with the descendants of the dissentic community.
That's what you're talking about.
I definitely don't want, I'm not trying to debate here.
I just want to make sure you saw the original bill said by June 30th, 2028.
Well, the intent of this was so that it was just, it would just get done, period.
I don't think we want to go back and forth.
That's fine.
I was just trying to point that out.
You've raised an issue, and usually that's when you can disagree to disagree for now, but we'll work it out later, continue it later.
Any other questions for Representative Hart?
Thank you.
I'd like to address this to Mr.
Wilson just to confirm what I think you said.
Did you say – I thought I heard you say that 227C is a better place to put these changes.
By adding African-American to the Native American.
To the North American, the indigenous.
Okay, thank you.
That's what I thought you said.
I just wanted to be short.
Thank you.
Representative Darby.
I'm sorry that I'm confused.
I thought you were also agreeing that a section of cemeteries for the private cemeteries and for reinterment should also be included, that there were multiple conditions that had to be accounted for with the intent of this bill, which is to include the descendant community in treating the remains of African Americans.
So both 227 as well as 289.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Not to belabor this too much, but back to what Representative McHugh was saying and Representative Darby we're talking about the returning in a reinterring of caches etc now you would said before so if we went with with representative McHugh's language I believe you were talking about how there is a process.
You contact the descendant community, and then you sort of work out the details of when things are happening, or you sort of bargain in a sense.
So is that something that would happen anyway?
If you could expound on that, thanks.
Right.
So this law obviously wasn't in existence when the ports of burial occurred um and that's as i said it's how it's been going on the consultation back and forth and i said it's it's not something that is just done and it's over until those remains are ultimately put into a final resting place which they are not yet for various reasons um the descendant community is still consulted on every move even if that move is putting them into a different room in the same museum, they're consulted.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So I want to follow up on Representative Harvey Bolio's question.
So let's say the anthropology department at UNH, they're moving into a new building or a new floor, and they're cleaning out their basement, and they see a box of bones.
What happens?
Is that treated exactly the same way as if somebody was digging up a backyard and found bones, like as a medicaliner called well ideally they would have some paperwork that would suggest they're not part of a murder okay one would hope although i won't get into specifics but there has there was a recent situation where some remains were found in a facility um and there was no documentation whatsoever so we kind of had to start over on that one.
But barring strange occurrences like that, when human remains are found in museum collections or at universities, they're generally not going through the ME's office to verify that they're not part of a murder or any kind of follow-up play.
They do just jump into the procedure of trying to trying to identify again most of the time when you have remains in a museum setting they are not caucasian i would say the overwhelming amount has been native american over the years and those of course when they're discovered they have to immediately notify the national park service because it's federal jurisdiction then they go through the whole nagpur process if it was african-american and they've the first step would be identifying you know what ethnicity if the paperwork doesn't already tell you um luckily at unh in your example they have forensic anthropologists right there that would do the analysis and would ultimately say like well this is these aren't african-american native american or whatnot and then the the correct or the um the the descendant community or next of kin would be identified and we'd go from there.
And there's actually an ongoing case right now at UNH that's following the procedures.
But they're following procedures, but those procedures aren't established in statute.
It's just best practices.
Well, I mean, as far as just human remains in general, there are the procedures that they're in statute maybe not as specific as as are in here and honestly i mean in here is it talking about the every single there's still decisions outside of what's even written in here that have to be made by the people that are doing it um so i guess i can't answer that question completely it's what we do it's what has what we read i guess with any law there's interpretation that's how we interpret the law to be okay we identify the remains we have to figure out who the next candidate is a and go from there thank you that's our interpretation Thank you.
Yeah, microphone is better.
I'm looking for Mike.
I didn't find him either.
Okay.
Is there a date on which the issue with remains, burial, date which things don't apply, especially the Native American one.
If there are Native Americans, uh, full-blooded Native Americans who live, you know, I, I know some, and most, most of us do.
Uh, if when, when they pass that you don't use the, uh, Native American law, historical law relative to them?
Is that, you know, are they not covered under that?
Are they still?
Again, you asked kind of two questions there.
One was how, you know, what date or whatever.
so if Native American remains are held at a museum or anything else they need to be reported and and turned over repatriated uh to the second part of your question uh if they're part of our society today yes they're just like everyone else they have a birth certificate they for most people have a birth certificate social security card and all the rest of it so i guess the identifying of them and i i don't know i mean they would have kind of equal footing on that i don't honestly know i haven't had a case where nagpro applies to someone that someone's remains from that just passed away last week i don't know that you'd have to contact the national park service on that that's their jurisdiction oh.
Thank you.
My gut, my instinct is that no.
Yeah, it just doesn't seem.
I think it's more for things that have.
So put it this way, you can't collect human remains anymore, so it's not really.
If you have them, you're going to be in trouble outside of historical resources.
I was talking about graves, graveyards, things like that.
If some, talking about someone who was buried in 1900 or 1920.
Sure, so that's still going to be NAEPRA.
If you're talking about someone that got buried in 1975 and they happen to be of Native American lineage, I think if you have those remains, I think you're probably going to get in trouble under other laws.
I don't think we're going to have to go through NAGPRA on that one.
Again, not having the remains, just moving.
I think someone that's buried in 1975, most likely you're going to be covered by just the traditional cemetery laws because most likely those remains buried in 1975 are buried in a cemetery that's marked and has all the regular protections, as opposed to this law is really talking more about unmarked burials, you know, higher likelihood of unmarked burials be native american african american poor white people marginalized communities any other any other questions Let's see.
I can go on, but I know I'll let you...
Does anyone else have any statement?
Anyone want to get involved and they have a question?
I know there's people...
I see you've raised your hand several times.
I'll just make one-minute comment.
I'm Jennifer Goodman.
Oh, yeah.
Well, thank you for your time and attention on this.
I'm Jennifer Goodman with the New Hampshire Preservation Alliance, the nonprofit sister, basically, of the Division of Historical Resources.
So I appreciate the time and the conversation.
I guess I wanted to put a plug in again.
Appreciate the amendment lining things up right in statute, but I wanted to put in a plug for the encouragement for the institutions, the historical societies and museums to reflect on their their collections and consider what they have and what steps they might take.
And my understanding is from some of your hard work on this last year, going to this year, there was the change from saying shall, is that correct, that those local institutions, those institutions shall inventory and take these steps to an encouragement to do so.
So I just wanted to put in a plug again for that, for this year, to hold that up as a way to suggest more good practice for those institutions across the state.
Anyone else?
I do have one additional question.
I think the way I've heard it phrased here is that everyone's treated the same, but that's not what the law says.
I mean, you're trying to treat everyone, all that you dig up, or anything that comes before you, you try to treat in the same manner.
But statutorily, only lists the Native Americans.
Is there a way that we can make the bill such that it treats everybody the same statutorily?
Well, sure.
You can write it however you want.
Okay.
Then all right.
So all right.
That's very good.
Thank you.
Any other questions by anyone here?
If not.
And I'd be remiss if I didn't apologize for missing the original hearing.
I had another conflict, and I apologize.
And we're happy to be available for questions going forward.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming.
Appreciate it.
Very good.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you very much.
I don't know about you.
Yes, I don't know about you guys, but I'm kind of tearing it out.
You want to close the work session?
So I'm going to close the work session.
Thank you.